this is harder than I thought it would
be
Matthew Perry says he felt nothing when
friends came to an end well I do believe
that levity saves Our Lives the actor
gets candid in his Memoir friends lovers
and the big terrible thing opening up
about his struggles with addiction
confessing that when the hit 90 sitcom
came to an end after 10 seasons in 2004
he was the only one who didn't cry quote
Jennifer Aniston was sobbing after a
while I was amazed she had any water
left in her entire body even Matt
LeBlanc was crying but I felt nothing it
was just a real and once her Gates
opened then it was I couldn't shut it
off you couldn't even I didn't plug it I
didn't no nothing I I still was just
like generally are you crying as much as
me she's like yeah Matthew jokes said he
couldn't tell if his lack of emotion was
because of the detox medication he was
taking or if he was just generally dead
inside but instead of crying he took a
slow walk around the stage do you guys
have to go to the new house right away
or do you have some time
we got some time
okay should we get some coffee
sure
where
of course the cast reunited 17 years
after the show wrapped in 2021. first
couple of years like we we ate every
meal together that's right
even on the weekend
every show together Super Bowl though
all of us
and they opened up to E.T about their
strong bond even after all these years
we really grew close as a family and
part of the reason was that that initial
success of the show was something that
no other no one else could relate to or
or was going through except the other
five actors so
um we really we really got close because
of that experience too there was
something that was laid down at the very
very beginning that kind of went into
our neural Pathways that we instantly it
was in our DNA that we were family we
were going to take care of each other
we're the most grateful women that I
know who have been able to be a part of
something like this and Matthew Echoes
all that in his book calling friends a
safe place and a touchstone of calm
quote it had given me a reason to get
out of bed every morning and it had also
given me a reason to take it just a
little bit easier the night before it
was The Time Of Our Lives you get into
that uh you get into a place in your
life where you're having a problem and
you either you know lie down about it or
step up to Baton
take your uh take your swing and that's
what I did it wasn't it wasn't really a
choice it was just
that's what I have to do because
there's so much out there that I like
and I didn't want to lose any of it you
know even I knew only a Madman which in
many moments I had been nonetheless
would screw up a job like that
[Music]